the u.s. cable giant Comcast owner of
NBC television and Universal films today
table to twenty two point 1 billion
pound bid or Trump's 21st Century Fox's
offer which is currently being held up
by regulators and that's a deal already
overshadowed by Disney's proposed
takeover of Fox's entertainment assets
or sky shares searched today two levels
not seen in almost two decades says the
city right to smell a bidding war and
what a Fox and Disney do next well the
FTS global media editor matthew Guerra
Han is with me now to help elucidate
matter did you see this coming
there was some suggestion that Comcast
were were interested in all of the Fox
assets I think before Disney announced
his deal to buy those assets including
the stake in sky Comcast's were in there
and looking around I don't think anyone
expected them to to you know hit them
hit the ground running in the way they
did today early in the morning 7 o'clock
with an announcement that they were
gonna make him move this guy and not
with the price like this I mean pendous
on the money well in many ways it
reflects a lot of that a lot of which
has changed with sky in the last even in
the last few weeks with the recent
Premier League deal that a lot of
savings there which is going to flow
straight to the bottom line we're gonna
make that those savings going to make
sky it more attractive some of the
analysts say that you know factor that
in it's worth 13 pounds of share which
is around the level that Comcast is
looking at Comcast is massive company in
America a hundred and eighty four
billion u.s. dollars market
capitalization well known over here I
mean what do people need to know about
them well it's a long family-owned
family controlled companies like like
like Fox deal class share structure the
Robert's family of owned it since its
inception I think in 1963 bought a cable
system in Tupelo Mississippi and built
it up built it into this in its enormous
sprawling media conglomerate there on
NBC Universal they own the Universal
Studios movie studios you said theme
parks around the world Harry Potter
theme park in Florida and other places I
mean it's it's a big hefty company but
its core business is in cable and cable
distribution in the United States so the
big question a lot of people will have
is because Comcast's were originally
interested in Fox's entertainment assets
as well with all they agreed to sell
those to Disney is this just a gambit to
get Fox back around the table to talk
about those assets or is it simply after
sky do you think well I think
unclear I think they they offered more
money than the Disney did for Fox but
Fox like the the aspect of getting
shares and Disney and they like the fact
that would be regular a regular tree
perspective would be a lot easier to
push through in the United States sky is
kind of you know not necessary the next
best thing but there's a there's a
clearer path for Comcast to buy Sky a
lot of synergies with its with its US
business business they are pretty much
landlocked in the u.s. in terms of their
growth this would be a big opportunity
for me to grow in Europe skies a
pan-european player so there's a lot of
attraction there when we spoke to Brian
Roberts this morning and came into the
FT for to talk about the rationale for
the deal Roberts Tom costs Congress CEO
yeah you know you made a pretty
compelling case that there's a lot of
overlap there like the sky technology
the sky cubox they're like Sky News for
example they committed to preserving
that and preserving its independence so
there's a lot there I think that makes
sense for them the big question I guess
is what happens next
from the fox's point of view from Disney
Parmenter does Fox now come back with a
higher offer for sky does Disney even
decide to just cut out the middleman go
direct this is where I get to come gets
complicated so that there's a binding
offer for Fox from Disney Fox has
already made a binding off of the sky
itself if it's gonna up its offer
obviously it's you know Disney's gonna
have to help in that regard Fox will
have to make the commitment to do it
itself but you know if the Murdock's
offered it and then didn't get anything
out of Disney delete into their their
end in terms of their sale of those Fox
assets to Disney so we expect that once
the the deal is cleared regulators once
the Fox Sky offer has cleared the CMA
and has received government approval
which we expect it to receive that at
that point Fox makes a bigger offer with
Disney's as Disney's help and then you
have a full-on bidding war with Comcast
it could be fascinating good news or
what's that haven't you but just to be
clear youth you assume that the
government is going to give regulatory
approval to the Fox takeover at Sky now
that the once the CMA have finished
looking at it we spoke about this thing
last time I was here but this the CMA
laid out a sort of roadmap for success
for for Fox and Fox has been in this
recent public statements as sort of
suggested it's it's inclined to do the
things the CM 8
you know so it would be acceptable
remedies such as ring-fencing scary news
from the influence of the Murdock family
and those are sort of you know
relatively minor things in the scheme of
things when you think about the fact
that Disney's going to end up owning
these assets anyway but of course the
pitchers now Maggio with Comcast in the
frame to it certainly as well thanks for
helping us to clear for a bit Matt Gower
Han from the FT could see